معنا الآن العميد المتقاعد
بيتر زواك، وهو
زميل عالمي في معهد كانون التابع لمركز ويلسون
وعمل كمقاول دفاعي كبير للولايات المتحدة
لجنرال الاتحاد الروسي. انظر، أريد أن أبدأ
بهجمات الطائرات بدون طيار على موسكو هنا، وهذا هو
الحدود الأوكرانية حوالي 300
ميل اعتمادًا على الاتجاه الذي تتجه إليه
من داخل أوكرانيا، أريد أن أظهر
للناس المواقع داخل روسيا أو في
الأراضي التي تسيطر عليها روسيا والتي
تم قصفها خلال الأسابيع القليلة الماضية،
يمكنك أن ترى أن معظم المناطق لها علاقة
بـ  الاحتلال الروسي مباشرة
لأوكرانيا إما مناطق الإمداد أو
منطقة التل الروسي داخل أوكرانيا
تقف موسكو وحدها كهدف مختلف كثيرًا
الآن، وينفي الأوكرانيون
تورطهم المباشر، لكن ماذا تفعل هجمات الطائرات بدون طيار
في موسكو للأوكرانيين
حتى لو لم يفعلوا ذلك
جيدًا  صباح الخير جون وللمشاهدين،
نعم، إنه أمر مهم للغاية،
ما يحدث هنا هو أن
الروس يتم تغذيتهم بسرد
حول عدالة هذا أه العسكري،
العملية العسكرية الخاصة
وسوف ينتصرون ومع ذلك فهم كذلك
فقط اجعل الكرملين
قد ضرب اه الشهر الماضي اه لقد
ضربوا موسكو في الضواحي
الآن اه اه
والطائرات بدون طيار قادمة
من مكان ما اه إنه نطاق متطرف
إذا أردت الطائرات بدون طيار العضوية الأوكرانية
تاشكا أو  أه السيارات السوداء القادمة
من تركيا لو كانت بعيدة عن
الحدود ولكن خلاصة القول هي أنهم
لا يستطيعون إخفاء الحرب أه منها إذا كنت سأسمي
المدن الآن ما يمكن أن أسميه
روسيا السائدة فإن الفاتورة تدفع لنا معظم الحرب
في أوكرانيا، كان معظمها
للقوات القادمة من المقاطعات ولكن
عليهم الآن التعامل معها
والمدونون العسكريون متواجدون هناك وقد
انتقدوا
الجيش مرة أخرى منذ بضع ساعات فقط
بسبب عدم فعاليتهم في
الدفاع  الوطن الأم وكل ذلك
أمر مربك للغاية بالنسبة لأه بالنسبة
لبوتين والكرملين
في محاولة الحفاظ على الوقود
سردًا مستقرًا، إنه أمر كبير
أكبر بكثير من الفعلي أه بعض
الضربات نعم ومرة ​​أخرى وهذا
فيديو  كيف بدت الضربة
داخل موسكو، هذا النوع من الصور يُرى
في كييف في كل مرة تقريبًا عدة مرات
في اليوم، هذه بعض مقاطع الفيديو الخاصة
بأغنية الهجوم الرئيسية والتي ظلت
بلا هوادة على مدار الأيام العديدة الماضية
ليلاً ونهارًا، لماذا  الروس
يضربون الآن بمثل هذه الشراسة في
العاصمة الأوكرانية،
أعتقد أولاً وقبل كل شيء أنني كنت
هناك مع وفد
مبادرة الديمقراطية المتجددة آه والمنظمات غير الحكومية التي تركز على مكافحة
الاستبداد في جميع
أنحاء العالم محليًا الآن هنا أم
أعتقد أنها مجموعة من الأسباب
هناك غضب شديد، هناك غضب
مستمر منذ أشهر ولكن
خاصة بعد ضربة الكرملين، هناك
جانب من الروس جون
أعتقد أنهم يريدون ما يريدون من
الأوكرانيين أن يستسلموا، إنها كلمة تكاد تكون من
العصور الوسطى، وهم ليسوا كذلك
و  كلما قاوم الأوكرانيون أكثر،
وكلما خلق الأوكرانيون
مشاكل في المنطقة، أصبح الأمر أكثر صعوبة
ولم يفهموا الأمر،
وأعتقد أيضًا أن الروس يحاولون الآن بشكل متزايد
أنهم يشعرون بالتوتر الشديد بشأن
كل الحديث عنه
هجوم مضاد في الاستعدادات أه،
عمليات التشكيل للجميع،
وهكذا فإنهم يشنون هجومًا
بطريقة ما،
والشيء المهم هو
أن هؤلاء لا يضربون
أهدافًا عسكرية بشكل فعال، بل
يضربون أهدافًا في المقام الأول  هناك الكثير من
المدنيين وهم يقتلون، وإذا كان
الروس يعتقدون أن ذلك سيجعل
الأوكرانيين يستسلمون من وجهة نظرنا في
مجموعتي بأنني كنت معهم كنا هناك في
الليلة الكبيرة الأولى من
الضربات الصاروخية وكييف في السادس عشر من الشهر الجاري.  في شهر مايو عندما
أه صواريخ باتريوت وأشياء أخرى
أسقطت صواريخ كروز روسية من الدرجة الأولى،
لذلك كان الأوكرانيون عنيدون
أه الروس يشعرون
بالإحباط المتزايد ويشعرون
بالقلق بشكل متزايد وأعتقد أن الأمر
يعود إلى
جنرال الكرملين بيترسوياك، شكرًا جزيلاً لك
على مساعدتنا هذا الصباح، سنتحدث
إليك مرة أخرى قريبًا،
أطفال مرعوبون يهربون للنجاة
بحياتهم بينما شنت روسيا
هجومًا جويًا ضخمًا آخر على
المدن الأوكرانية، لكن أوكرانيا تقول إن دفاعها الجوي
تمكن من إسقاط جميع
الصواريخ الباليستية.  تم إطلاق النار على مبنى الكابيتول في كييف،
والآن تبدو القوات الأوكرانية جاهزة تقريبًا
لهجومها المضاد الذي طال انتظاره
في نهاية هذا الأسبوع. أصدر الجنرال الأوكراني الأعلى
لاري زالوشني هذا الفيديو الذي
يظهر القوات تستعد للمعركة
وتعرض الأسلحة الغربية الحديثة مع
رسالة واضحة مفادها أن الوقت قد حان لـ  استردوا
ما هو لنا
وهذا ما يدربه هؤلاء الرجال.
هذه وحدة من
الحرس الهجومي من الصناعة الداخلية في أوكرانيا
لدينا دافع واضح
يقول القائد إننا ندافع عن أرضنا هذه
أمتنا وطننا الحرس الهجومي
يحشد عشرات الآلاف  من الجنود الذين
يقولون إنهم يتدربون على اقتحام الخنادق
وإجلاء الضحايا الذين يعلمون أنهم
سيواجهونهم في
المعارك الصعبة المقبلة، لكن هؤلاء الرجال الذين
يتدربون هنا سيصبحون بلا شك
حقيقة بالنسبة للقوات المسلحة الأوكرانية
قريبًا جدًا حيث تقول كييف إنها ستبدأ
هجوم مضاد واسع النطاق لاستعادة
جميع أراضيهم بما في ذلك شبه جزيرة القرم،
يبدو أن الأوكرانيين
يكثفون بالفعل ضرباتهم على
خطوط الإمداد الروسية المحتملة في المناطق المحتلة.
مسؤولون روس مثبتون يزعمون
هجمات صاروخية أوكرانية ضد أهداف حول
بيرديانسك وماريوبول في جنوب شرق
أوكرانيا في الماضي
إنها مجرد بداية، يخبرني أحد كبار مستشاري
الرئاسة الأوكرانية أن
كل ما يحدث الآن هو
مقدمة لهجوم مضاد،
ومقدمة ضرورية حيث
تزداد شدة النيران
ويضع أهدافًا جريئة للهجوم
المضاد
الذي سينتهي بلا شك.  على حدود
أوكرانيا كما كانت في عام 1991 مع
احتلال شبه جزيرة القرم ومع
بداية عملية ضخمة
لتحويل النظام السياسي الروسي،
لكن في الوقت الحالي تظل المرونة أمرًا
أساسيًا للناس في المدن الأوكرانية، حيث كان
هؤلاء المتزوجون الجدد قد عقدوا قرانهم للتو
وكانوا  في طريقهم إلى
احتفالهم عندما انطلقت صفارات الإنذار للغارة الجوية،
لذلك استمروا في
الاحتفال في الملجأ متعهدين بعدم
السماح للصواريخ الروسية بإفساد
أفضل يوم في حياتهم
لقناة سي إن إن كييف.